Yeah,
yeah,
well human made,
global warming is caused by changes in
the atmosphere which are due to burning
fossil fuels,
primarily as we burn oil,
gas,
and coal.
This releases carbon dioxide to the
atmosphere.
Carbon dioxide absorbs heat,
radiation from the earth and that traps
the heat radiation and makes the planet
a bit warmer,
so we noticed that the world has warmed
up about one and a half degrees
Fahrenheit in the last century.
With most of that warming in the last 30
years.
Well there's now 387 parts per million
of co two in the atmosphere.
I'm 150 years ago it was 280,
so it's increased by 107 ppm.
What we thought a few years ago was that
it would probably be safe to let CEO to
go as high as 450 parts per million.
The reason we thought that was that we
know that there were previous periods in
the earth's history called interglacial
periods.
We're now in a warm interglacial period,
which we have been in for about 12,000
years,
but there were prior periods when the
earth was warmer than it is now,
and the planet was still pretty much the
way it is now
and we thought that it was then about a
degree or so Celsius,
which is about two degrees Fahrenheit
warmer than it is now,
and we thought that might be okay to be
that warm and 450 parts per million
would probably take us to that sort of
climate,
but what we now realize is that during
those prior warm periods,
sea level was about six or seven meters
higher than it is now,
and also we see what's happening with
the current 387 parts per million.
That's already enough that the Arctic
sea ice is melting.
Mountain glaciers all around the world
are melting,
which is going to affect the fresh water
supply for billions of people.
The climate zones are shifting,
so the southwest United States and
Mediterranean region are becoming hotter
and drier.
Likewise,
Australia,
so you see increased forest fires and
reduced water supplies in those regions.
Coral reefs are already under stress.
They're going to.
Many of them are going to be lost if we
continue with increasing greenhouse
gases,
so we realize already the 387 is
actually two large,
about 350 parts per million is a more
realistic target and that means we're
going to have to phase out use of coal
over the next couple of decades.
If we want to be able to get back to 350
parts per million.
We simply,
if we look at the fossil fuels and we
see how much carbon there is an oil,
gas and coal,
and by far the largest is cold and we
know that we're going to use the oil and
the gas.
It's very.
They're very convenient fuels.
The big pools are owned by Russia and
Saudi Arabia.
There are certainly going to sell that
gas and oil.
If we want to be able to get back to 350
parts per million.
It's this huge coal reserves that we're
going to have to leave in the ground,
or we could burn the coal and capture
the co two and put it back in the
ground,
but that's very difficult.
We're going to have to move beyond
fossil fuels sometime within the next
century anyway,
so why not do it now and preserve a
climate that will allow our children and
grandchildren to have the same sort of
planet that we enjoy and with all of the
species that are still on the planet.